Apple aficionados queued outside the  selected shops where the device is on  display sales of the smart watches  haven't started yet but these people  wanted to get a first close-up look of  the wristband computer chapter your  finger finish I hope it'll let me know  when I've received an email I read that  there will be some kind of vibration  that's very cool it's an indie record  and huge toy but the smart watched as  more than just show emails the mini  computer also collects information about  its wearers their locations heart rates  and much more critics say the collected  data could easily be misused but that  doesn't seem to bother Apple fans that's  one balloon cannot you can touch someone  else through the watch if they are also  wearing one this will revolutionize  communication in general it's yet  edition counts on this Apple is  expecting tidy revenues from the devices  analysts expect the company to sell up  to 15 million units this year